hello everyone welcome to today's bio
conference
webinar i'm bob woodard and i'll be
moderator for today's event
before we start i have a few
announcements to make
this webcast is designed to be
interactive we encourage you to ask
questions during the event
you can submit questions by typing them
into the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems while
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on click on the support
button in the upper right hand corner of
the presentation window or submit your
problem through the green q a button on
the lower left
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr john bradfield
dr bradfield is the senior director of
the association for the assessment and
accreditation of laboratory animal care
he is a veterinarian and a diplomate of
the american college of laboratory
animal medicine
dr batfield also has a phd in
experimental pathology with scholarly
publications in various areas of
laboratory animal medicine
wound healing and vascular and platelet
biology
please join me
in welcoming dr bradfield i will now
turn the presentation over to him
hello everyone welcome to this
presentation on training and
conferencing research animal programs
um as bob said i'm john bradfield uh
coming to you from our offices in
frederick maryland
uh at the alac office
got a
three basic segments to today's uh
presentation
uh regarding training and animal care
programs first just a few brief
introductory remarks on requirements of
course that's going to vary a lot
depending on where you are in the world
so it's much too detailed of a topic to
cover in in a lot of depth but we'll
cover the highlights for a couple of
major geographical areas then i'll move
into some alac trend data
which i think illustrates where programs
tend to have difficulties
and challenges associated with training
and competency
and then the last part of the program
will involve assessments
strategies for how you assess the
effectiveness of training programs and
ways to go about that so i hope you find
it helpful
with that let's get started
so this next slide sort of illustrates
from the guide from the karen use point
of view the ilar guide if you will
those various groups of people who need
training
so the guide is widely used in the us
and in many places around the globe so i
think it's a good place to turn to first
to look for some basic guidelines about
the kinds of people in the animal
program that need training
there's a lot of sections in this
newest edition of the guide the 2011
version there's two different sections
of the page numbers listed there on
screen
47 separate text references and 15 pages
cited in the index so this new iteration
of the guide has a lot more language
about training and who needs it
specifically they mentioned four major
groups of people in the animal program
i cook member training training for the
animal care staff
obviously the veterinary staff and their
qualifications and training as well as
investigators and their staffs and the
training involved for them so the guide
identifies those four key groups of
people as needing training in order to
be competent in what they do
of course in the u.s there's the animal
welfare regulations as well that has
something to say about training that'll
come up in a minute and for aylak when
we do accreditation site visits we also
use the ag guide the fast ag guide as a
reference as well as ets 123 and any
regulations in the country in which
we're doing the site visit also apply
so the guide has this particular
statement on page 15
that really is all-encompassing and it
sort of gets to the crux of the matter
and there's a few big words in this
passage
all personnel there's that's unequivocal
as to who they're talking about in the
animal care program so that's all
personnel involved with animal care and
use must and the guide uses that word
intentionally that is a
mandatory requirement if you will
to be adequately educated trained or
qualified
so that's a pretty all-encompassing
statement from the guide that really
is uh can be quite problematic when you
think about terms of training program
and how to implement that
i mentioned the animal welfare
regulations here in the u.s uh i won't
go into depth in this but they're listed
here on this uh screen
section 2.32 the the regulations
pinpoint technicians animal technicians
scientists plus others sort of a big
category
again you see the must work training and
instruction of personnel must include
various things
and that this must be ongoing at
sufficient frequency so a pretty tall
order again in the regulations
must include humane methods
and they list basic needs of each animal
species handling and care pre-procedural
post-procedural care and aseptic
surgical techniques
they go on to say that additional
training topics include uh training in
the limit in the use of animals and and
those procedures that minimize pain and
distress anesthetics analgesics
tranquilizers and training on how to
report deficiencies interestingly enough
in the regulations
and then finally point five here in the
regs
you uh training should be provided
to let people know about the
services available to provide
information on appropriate methods of
animal care and use alternatives to the
use of animals avoiding unnecessary
duplication and about the animal welfare
act itself so a real brief overview of
the regulations in the u.s
if we look to europe
uh the european directive has very clear
language again about requirements for
training and i like the term that the
directive uses here in article 23
that
personnel should be competent
they should be shall be adequately
educated and trained before they perform
any of the following
carrying out procedures on animals
designing uh projects taking care of
animals or animal euthanasia
so the directive is quite clear that
personnel need to be competent before
they engage in any of those activities
at the bottom of this screen you see an
a url that is a i think a quite valuable
guidance document these are guidelines
developed in february this year
conference in brussels
that's a very detailed document on how
to implement
the requirements of the directive for
european member straight states
whether in europe or not i think this is
a pretty valuable resource so if you're
not familiar with it
i'd encourage you to look at this
document
as you're considering ways to develop or
augment your training programs
a little bit more detail on this
document
it's it's entitled a working document
for the development of common education
and training framework to fulfill the
requirements the directive big name i'll
refer to it as the brussels document
it's about a hundred pages long it's
very detailed and comprehensive
uh there is a lot of detail in there
that is worthwhile it outlines the
structure and component of training
programs in more particular this idea of
competency which i think is a good one
training is one thing competency is
another and the the these guidelines as
well as the directive itself
really highlights that point
towards the end of the document there
are suggested training modules in their
content so it's a good place to look at
those there's 22 of them they offer it's
being worthwhile to consider
various functions like
core and functional tasks to meet the
the
intent of the directive as well as skill
based tasks for other modules and again
the url there is at the bottom of this
screen so if you're not familiar with
that document i'd encourage you to look
at it whether you're in europe or
anywhere else around the globe
so we think about training and uh we
develop programs because
of all these requirements to train
personnel to be adept at the procedures
they conduct whether it be animal care
or scientific methods
and so we offer training and we usually
consider that good we offer training
people required to take it end of story
well this brussels guidance document
gives us an idea that there's a lot more
steps to this process when you think
about competency
so they uh they suggest for studies that
involve the potential for animal pain
and distress the training obviously
occurs that's the first step
um but really
one might sort of look at this a
pass assessment that's just an
assimilation of the training materials
there are many other steps involved in
this chain of competency uh
working under supervision
evaluating deeper learning and then a
competency
exam or test of some sort to determine
that skills are met and that this is
sort of a cyclic stage
that occurs ongoing over time to
maintain skills and perform competency
tests so it's not just a one-and-done
training so to speak there are multiple
steps it's ongoing
not a trivial task
okay
let me shift gears a little bit and
talk about some alac findings with
regard to uh program assessments that we
do around the globe
and uh how often training comes up as an
issue and whether or not there are any
common trends in training deficiencies
so i'm going to give you a little bit of
background material here in a next
couple of slides about our data set and
where it comes from so you can sort of
assess uh
the the breadth and scope of of these
these data
so we have a around 930 accredited units
across the globe
in the alac family if you will these are
institutions who use animals and we do
site visits to these 930 institutions at
least once every three years
that translates to about 100 plus
site visits every trimester
300
site visits a year so this is a busy
activity that alac engages in you may
know that if you if you're part of a a
like accredited institution that at the
end of a site visit we offer commentary
that we call the exit briefing these are
preliminary findings of the site visit
team
and we leave you with a list of things
that we think your program does
particularly well
and strengths as well as any issues of
concern that we have
so this data set i'll describe here in a
minute is all the comments
left at the institutions
at the exit briefing
if we look at how these accredited
institutions are dispersed around the
globe this map sort of gives you an idea
of where the accredited institutions are
we began years ago and exactly 50 years
ago
in north america so a good number of our
institutions are in north america
with europe and the pacific rim making
the bulk of the international community
but south america latin america and
other places around the globe are also
involved in that so 300 uh site visits a
year around the globe you're getting a
pretty fair representative of a lot of
different institutions in the findings
that you're about to see
one last bit of demographics here before
we get to the findings if we look at the
accredited community as a whole
you see that the
big
sector there is the commercial sector
followed by academia government
nonprofit and hospital so just another
thing to keep in mind as we go through
these findings
this data set
is all the exit briefing remarks made
from fall 2011 to december 2013.
4815 findings
671 site visits so it's a lot of
comments we sipped it through
and we sort of analyze these every few
years to see
where institutions may have common
challenges in managing their animal
program
to give you an idea of the
big picture here before we drill down on
training and
competency
we look at programs in terms of
six basic program components animal
environment occupational health and
safety
the iacook or ethics committee
veterinary care program
the physical plant or the animal
facilities themselves in a category we
call institutional administration
those are the things program-wide that
institutions need to accomplish in order
to conduct a scientific enterprise with
animals that institutional
administration component is this sort of
amber block here 10 percent of all those
4 815 findings fall into that category
that's where we place training so we'll
be talking about that piece of the pie
for the next few slides here
if we look at this category of
institutional administration what occurs
there
number one most cited category within
institutional administration is
documentation and record keeping
probably not a big surprise we have to
keep a lot of documents and records in
the animal care program
that can be challenging
the guide for example says that all
training records should be maintained
and documented
the number two category there is our
topic of interest today training
so we find this issue
not uncommonly when we do site visits we
find concerns relative to training
in fact some of the documentation issues
are documentation gaps with the training
program so if we combine those two
things training may very well become the
most often cited category in this
institutional administration portion of
the program and the other components you
can sort of see here the a-lac program
description concerns with that issues
with disaster plan authority and
responsibility to keep personnel like
the attending veterinarian institutional
official iacoc
and then this other category
so if we look at training a little bit
more closely what do we see
the most common category cited
on these a-lac site visits are issues
regarding personal training and
occupational health and safety
how well they are trained or not with
regard to their risks of animal exposure
following that is a category we call
technical qualifications these are all
the things people need to know to either
care for animals or conduct procedures
with at the bench top involving animals
and that's the number two category we
see with regard to training the third
one here you can see is the ayakook or
oversight body
that's training members of the iacook to
do their job well the icook is such a
central role in animal program
management how well do institutions
train their members to fulfill their
responsibilities
and the third and smallest category you
see on the screen
is when institutions have training
deficits in more than one of these other
three categories so
training is something we see as an issue
quite regularly
it's not the largest portion of the
program in terms of challenges that we
see but it's of interest i think to note
that 21 of all training deficiencies we
see are mandatory deficiencies that
means they're of sufficient concern
that alac requires the institution to
address that issue in order to maintain
its accreditation
of course the remaining uh training
issues are what we call sfis or
suggestions for improvement so they're
less concerning but still think they'd
be valuable for your institution to
address
in terms of incidents eighteen percent
of site visits or eighteen out of a
hundred or one in six site visits we are
finding an issue with regard to training
so not uncommon at all
so that's that big data set how often we
identify training
and uh the challenges that institutions
tend to have with regard to technical
training and occupational health
training and i cook member training
so i'll shift to the third segment of my
presentation
that gets to
how can you assess the training program
in your institution how does it work
what are some of the strategies you
might employ
this can be quite challenging and i'll
go over some of that at the very end the
challenges we think
institutions
have with regard to assessing their
training program so i'll offer four
general ways to get your finger on the
pulse as to how well your training
program might be working
and this first one goes back to this
notion articulated well in the european
directive that is of competency
not just are people trained have we
given them a training module they passed
a post-assessment test
and now they're good to go
there may actually need to be a robust
competency test or or
assessment in place
to really tell whether or not people
assimilate and can practice what was
offered in the training program
so does the competency test really
discern between a person who may
understand the training and someone who
doesn't this is not an easy thing to do
developing a competency testing program
and who needs to be involved how often
that needs to occur
and can it
discern between those who are good at a
particular job versus those that need
some additional training
that's no small undertaking
but
our goal is to have people that are well
trained and so a competency testing
method of some sort
is one way
to sort of assure yourself as an
institution that you're accomplishing
what you intend with your training
program
so there's many ways to do that and uh
way too many and too much detail for us
to cover in a short presentation today
but we all understand that competency
testing is can be of great value
particularly if the test is detailed and
comprehensive
another method i'm just simply calling
the alac method and for those of you
that host abac site visits once every
three years you'll recognize this very
well
this is a way this is a technique that
site visit teams use when they assess an
institution
to
get a feel for how effective the
training program is and how well
implemented
the methods and the expectations of the
institutional program are put in place
so quite simply we walk around and visit
animal use areas those places where
animals get used procedure areas and
investigator laboratories surgery areas
necropsy areas those critical points
where animal use tends to occur
we
have very detailed observations and we
interview folks
we're basically information gathering
and we do this by asking very general
open-ended questions
um you tend to ask what people do and
they will often tell you
and you have to ask in a detailed way so
that you get the information you need to
determine whether or not the person
you're talking to is competent to do the
things they're supposed to do
with animals
we look for trends if we're talking to a
person in a lab and there are some gaps
in their knowledge or understanding that
may be an issue with one person
but if we talk with let's say we visit
ten labs and four of ten labs have an
issue let's say with aseptic technique
and rodent surgery
then the trend seems to be emerging
there that maybe the training program
with aseptic surgery may not be
sufficiently robust because we're seeing
four out of ten
people interviewed about aseptic
technique not measuring up
so
we we walk around and we talk to people
it's not very fancy but it's pretty
effective
we compare the answers that people give
with the animal care and use protocols
if there's any standard operating
procedures or guidelines institutional
expectations
policies of the program we compare
answers we get in the lab or in the
procedure area
with what the institution expectations
are
and if trends emerge then alac will say
we may have an issue here with your
training program that might need to be
tightened up
some example questions since these are
sort of open-ended and generic questions
but you'd be surprised how much
information you can elicit when you just
talk to folks and ask very basic
questions so again if you've experienced
nail excited visit these will look very
familiar to you i'll go through these
quickly i think their value is
self-evident
but
we'll start out with very general
questions
and get people to talking to find out
what they know and how well-trained they
were
something very basic initially like
describe the animal procedures you
conduct in the lab
they'll tell you
and sometimes you're surprised at what
the answers are when you ask an
open-ended question like that are animal
procedures performed in the lab
described in the protocol
it gets to whether or not they know
what's in the protocol and whether or
not what they're doing is an approved
procedure
as everyone in the lab read the
protocols usually folks we talk to don't
know that the principal investigator
might because they might have a rule in
the lab a good one that everybody be
familiar with the protocols or at least
the protocols on which they are listed
as personnel conducting procedures
here's a good one what kinds of training
did you receive regarding animal
procedures you're conducting ask them
how they were trained
was it 10 years ago has there been any
retraining ask them detailed questions
once you start this line of questioning
and then ask them if there's any
documentation if not that's likely an
issue the guide sets down pretty clear
expectations that training documents be
maintained so you want to see those
as evidence that training ongoing
training relevant trainings occurring
either in the lab or at the iacocca or
wherever
and finally some some specific animal
care and use issues with this uh
these initial questions might be what
are the study endpoints what are the
humane endpoints these are details in
the protocol that get at animal care and
use issues relative to animal welfare
and well-being
common questions we ask on site visits i
would offer that these are good
questions to maybe involve in your
semi-annual evaluations or if you do
post approval monitoring visits to
incorporate these into your
post-approval monitoring
questions about surgery might include
something like
describe uh the surgery you do and more
specifically the sterile technique how
do you prepare the animal the surgeon
the instruments
where do you do it
combining what you observe with the
answers you get will give you pretty
clear idea if someone understands the
tenets
of aseptic surgical technique and
whether that's being conducted properly
i will tell you that this is a common
deficiency that we see if you look at
the institutional expectations they
offer training on surgery
oftentimes there's a test that folks
have to pass in order to conduct surgery
yet when aylat comes to town and asks
these questions about surgery there are
often common gaps that emerge about how
the technique is actually conducted
so that gets back to that competency so
this is a common area that we see issues
with with regard to aseptic surgery
particularly in rodents
how do you monitor the animals who does
that what is your training what do you
look for again it goes to
technical expertise to conduct a
surgical procedure
what anaesthetic agents do you use how
do you maintain
gas anesthetic machines if those are
used how is the gas scavenge personnel
protection again high pressure tanks
dosage calculations for injectables for
example
depending on the kind of anesthesia you
use you'd have many secondary questions
to get at a person's competence and
expertise
here's another big one
we often see gaps in how analgesics are
administered the protocol says one thing
the practice involves another so when
you ask these questions in the lab you
often get very illuminating answers
so what analgesics do you use what's the
schedule of administration and do you
document that
and finally uh
towards the end here are surgery records
kept and available for review what kind
of detail is in those surgical records
and the detail required may vary if it's
a very simple procedure maybe not much
detail is required if on the other hand
it's a thoracotomy involving a procedure
on a heart say
that's much more involved and we would
expect more detail with regard to
surgical records also goes
to
elucidate the training with regard to
the necessity for surgical record
keeping
and another big one that we we often see
issues with are controlled substances
and logs of usage and using them
according to whatever regulation and
guideline is in play in the country
we're in
so we'll ask about that too
some general questions about veterinary
care
how do you get animals to the lab do
they go through common corridors are the
cages covered are there occupational
health issues in other words with
getting animals from point a to point b
it gets it whether people understand
those issues and how they address them
ask how long animals stay in the lab
because it's important for animal care
and use committee and and
proper husbandry and care for the
animals
here's one that we always ask and it's
sometimes surprising the answers we get
what do you know if you notice a sick
animal or injured animal the answer
we're really looking for is we contact
the veterinary staff
but many times it's not the answer we
get in other words how well trained are
folks to recognize injury or sickness
and how what training did they receive
on how to address that in animals this
these really go to core principles of
animal welfare
describe how you euthanize animals and
how they were trained to euthanize
animals what exactly do you do
and have them walk you through these
various procedures step by step in great
detail you can learn a lot about what
somebody knows just by asking these
questions
and then finally related to veterinary
care we do with carcass disposal
sometimes there are hazardous issues
hazardous waste issues involved with
these kinds of
animal use procedures so you want to
know if people understand hazardous
containment
occupational health and safety questions
i think this is the last category i have
again these are just example questions
but they can really
get at how effective folks are trained
as i mentioned occupational health and
safety training deficits are one of the
most common we see
and so we'll often ask about that when
we're in these animal use areas is
everyone in the lab enrolled in the
occupational health program that's the
proverbial deer in the headlights look
because some folks don't know what the
occupational health program is it's very
telling so again if that's one person in
a lab somewhere who doesn't know about
the occupational health program that's
probably a one-person lab issue you can
address that as a focal issue
yet if we ask that of 10 15 20 people
and nobody knows or only a subset of
folks know what the occupational health
and safety program is
we're starting to believe that maybe
there's a trend and an issue emerging
about training
we ask about animal allergy big problem
with laboratory animal users is we want
to know what you know about laboratory
animal allergy
what do you do if you think you have an
allergy again a training with regard to
occupational health and safety and
someone's knowledge about how to get
ailments associated with their animal
use addressed
what risks do you have by virtue of your
animal contact and how are you trained
about that and what are they
and finally what occupational health
training have you received
these are tough questions for folks to
answer but they will really give you a
fair idea as to whether these broad
areas of the program have been addressed
in the training program ideally you
would want everybody you come into
contact with to be able to answer these
questions in great detail
so number one was competency testing
a good valuable way to do it but making
that reliable and relevant is
challenging
the a-lac method walking around asking a
bunch of questions and comparing those
with institutional expectations
the third strategy i hear i have here
for assessing training effectiveness is
what i'm calling error rate analysis
this can be quite helpful
that is being intentional about
monitoring
mishaps or errors
and
the incidence of those where they occur
and how they occur and analyzing why
they occur you have to do this
intentionally
a perfect example is that one of the
institutions i visited recently
monitored um the
ex the uh procedures with regard to
euthanasia
and particularly co2 euthanasia and how
often that was complete or incomplete
making sure that the procedure
uh humanely and completely euthanized
the animals and how often they had
problems with that
when they looked for that information
and ass started asking the questions
they found that really their incidence
was much higher than they knew about
they were uncomfortable with that and it
clearly pointed to the fact that people
needed more training with regard to
humane technique in euthanasia
really important with animal welfare and
it wasn't until that institution started
to ask questions about
how often do we have mistakes
were they able to tell that the training
program had a gap so that's what i mean
by error rate analysis got to be
intentional
so
getting reporting accurate reporting and
analysis of those mishaps
determining whether there are emerging
trends
it could be reports to the animal care
news committee if the veterinarian's
reporting that say
dogs are experiencing inner digital
cysts in their feet there may be an
issue with training with regard to how
the dog
pens and runs or cleaned and so it may
be worthwhile to go look at that
procedure in the training of people who
conduct that procedure just examples of
how incidence reporting can give you a
heads up on whether or not the training
program works
and of course technical training for the
vet and their staffs and and the pis as
well
are there issues say with endemic
disease in the rodent colonies
if there are
is the the health monitoring program
sufficient do the veterinarians have a
robust program implemented
if not why not is there insufficient
knowledge on the part of the veterinary
staff or what is the issue so
even monitoring things like incidents of
outbreaks and endemic disease and road
colonies might give you an idea about
training for veterinary staff
number four on the slide here i've got
as a sort of my final suggestion for um
monitoring training effectiveness and
that's simply by auditing critical
activities if you have folks conducting
tricky procedures
um invasive surgeries or other surgeries
or procedures that might involve
say restraint for long periods of time
those are procedures you might just
literally want to go watch
and and make sure that folks who do them
are adept in those procedures and doing
them according to expectations
so there are critical areas throughout
any animal care program things like
biocontainment where there's human
safety issues involved
barriers where there's animal safety and
involved and integrity of the science
involved so you know what those critical
areas of your program are
it's a good idea to have folks who know
how those procedures should be conducted
to audit those areas make sure things
are happening the way you expect them to
so it's not very fancy
but four methods to sort of get a good
handle on your overall programmatic
training program
so i'm wrapping up here we're getting
near the end uh this is not this this
training program
competency assessment um effectiveness
assessing how this all works is fraught
with challenges
uh i mentioned the glib term one and
done you offer a training prep module on
a particular topic somebody takes it and
everybody's good to go
unfortunately it doesn't work that way
these are usually ongoing as that
brussels document listed how do people
maintain
their skills and how do you ensure that
they do that so this is an ongoing
process
meaning that there's a tremendous
workload burden somebody has to monitor
this somebody has to do the training
somebody has to be intentional and error
rate analysis somebody has to walk
around and assess how well people are
doing it what they do
so making sure your training program is
focused i've got to comment here on the
slide be lean and efficient that means
don't ask people to do training they
don't really need
tailor these training programs which
takes time and effort
be intentional about that and don't ask
folks to do more training than is really
required
i've got remember the goal on the slide
here the goal is not to have a training
program
i don't think
the goal is to have people competent and
adept in the procedures that they
perform
involving animals and the care that they
provide to animals we want people to be
good at that
obviously training is involved but we
want people to be good so measure
their ability to be competent
rather than focus on the training itself
gives you a slightly different
perspective of the issue
another challenge
uh in no program that i've ever visited
were were the people who needed trained
a static population of people it's often
a very dynamic population of people
particularly with students who might
have animal contact
new people coming into the program all
the time this creates a real challenge
to keep them trained and up to speed
also
contemporary science today in scientific
enterprise is international it's global
multicultural
different languages
people bring their own
biases and understanding with them into
the lab
and the training program needs to
address all that it's a pretty tall
order so just a language barrier let
alone a cultural barrier
can be quite a challenge to make sure
that the objectives of training are met
and implemented
and finally worried about trainers
uh
back years ago i had a veterinary
technician who was
wonderful at venipuncture she could hit
any vein or vessel
that you needed and she could collect
blood and so who better
than this young lady to teach others how
to do proper blood collection techniques
and animals
well it didn't work just because she was
adept at the procedure didn't mean that
she was a good trainer in fact she had a
knack for it it was so easy for her she
became frustrated when others couldn't
understand how to do it so she was not
the best trainer even though she was
perfectly adept and knowledgeable
herself
so making sure the trainers are
effective in imparting the appropriate
information is another pretty tall order
i'll leave you with one final thought in
closing and this is something we see
time and again at alac site visits
when we see issues with regard to
training
it's usually because we've had an issue
with two or three
crucial aspects of animal care program
management one is animal well-being
deficits and training often impact
negatively
animal well-being
and maybe human safety
and maybe scientific integrity
so it's it's a lot of people
consider sort of a necessary evil to
have a training program but it really is
at the core
of good science and good animal care and
we see this all the time on site visits
with that i'll close my remarks and i
think we can probably go to q a
so i'll turn it back to uh bob woodward
so i'll turn it back to uh bob
well thank you dr bradfield for that
informative presentation
before we get started on the q a i'd
like to remind everyone how to submit
their questions
you can submit questions by typing them
in to the q a box which you can find by
clicking on the green q and a
button at the lower left of the
presentation window
and we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can
let's look at our first question here
it's um
this is a question from laura the
question is
is it possible to know how many labs in
colombia have a lack accreditation
if there are any you can tell me can you
tell me which ones
so let me turn that over to john for the
answer
accredited programs in colombia i don't
believe so but this is a
this is a answer that will change
literally three times a year every time
we have a council meeting to confer
accreditation on new applications uh
we'll often add new countries i think as
we currently stand we do not have an
accredited institution in colombia
to be sure you can visit the alac
website
alac.org and there is a listing of
accredited institutions on our website
be aware though that not all
institutions are listed there they can
choose to withhold their name if they
want to most institutions are listed but
not all so you can you can go and verify
that i think i'm giving you the right
information that no institutions in
colombia as of
right now but we do see a lot of
interest in activity
in latin america um
and i think we will probably see more
countries in that region of the globe
joining a lack in the coming year or a
couple years at least
okay we have next question is from
paulina
she would like to know during one of
your visits and after you've identified
deficiencies in regards to training how
do you sort them out
yeah i'm smiling because it's a great
question uh and it really can be a
challenge
when does
perhaps ask another way your question
might be when does an issue uh that we
have concern about become an issue about
say aseptic surgery
versus
an issue with training
and there's no hard and fast rule about
when we start to globalize the issue
across the program other than sort of an
incidence
that i mentioned it in the presentation
so if it's one or two labs out of a good
number that we visit that have a
particular issue say aseptic surgery
then we tend to think well this is not a
training issue this is probably an issue
specifically with that lab and how they
conduct surgery
so it might be a finding but we wouldn't
capture it as a training finding
on the other hand
at some point
we the site visit team will start to say
you know we're beginning to see a
theme emerge here
with regard to a number of people that
seem to be vague
or unclear
or poorly trained on a procedure or an
aspect of the program whether it be a
husbandry procedure or an experimental
procedure or surgery or what have you
if we start to see that occur with some
incidents throughout the site visit then
we say aha this may be a broader issue
than just the odd lab here or two it may
indeed be a training issue so it's not a
very good answer to your question but at
some point because of the incidence
and uh and perhaps the severity
it'll occur to us that it's really
larger than just one part of the program
and it encompasses many areas of the
program therefore a training issue
hope that helps
well dr bradfield the next question
isn't exactly a question but it's a um
it uh it's from russell and he says
thank you john for a great talk
several key points for everyone to take
home and present to their groups
so uh
let's see if you have any comments on
that
i appreciate the feedback
i find this a challenging topic to to
discuss
um
that notwithstanding i think it's a very
important topic i mentioned at the end
the issues with training and often
involve issues with animal well-being
and welfare scientific integrity or
human safety i mean what can be more
important than that
so it's a it's a tall order to
talk about and capsulize in a short
program the devil is in the details i
appreciate your comments um this is a
challenge for every program that i've
ever been involved with either as a site
visitor or as a veterinarian
and and i think
having sort of a general discussion and
format in which
what
we can discuss what works what the
challenges are and what doesn't is
always a good thing so i appreciate your
remarks
one last question from marcel
its question is what are the reasons
some institutions choose not to publish
their name as accredited in the alac
website
and for the answer
yeah that's a good question um i think
we can all
probably guess
but the motives might be different for
each institution and granted this is a
minority of institutions
i think
the institutional culture of some places
is to say fly below the radar they don't
necessarily want to advertise the fact
that they conduct
research that involves animals
some of that's probably the result of
experience negative experience with
extremists or attacks from extremists so
they have concerns about that
that's probably the most obvious reason
uh but there could be others and i'm
speculating here
again this doesn't happen frequently uh
most people are very proud of their like
accreditation and they're they're happy
to
to demonstrate that they're part of the
like family if you will but we
we honor an institution's
request for confidentiality and and so
we
will do that and not publish their name
if they don't
this question is from chris
the question is in your experience with
site visits
what has been a common response from
institutions in regards to findings of
deficiencies in their training programs
yeah it's a good question um the answer
the specific answer of how they tend to
address those issues
probably depends on the area
in which the gaps occur
if it's an issue with iacocc member
training
the common response is to
allocate resources to sendaiakook
members outside the institution for some
kind of formal training
institutions can get very provincial
in their level of understanding and so
to
help avoid that business businesses
usual kind of mentality they'll send i
cook numbers outside for additional
training we see that a lot we think
that's an effective strategy
if it involves occupational health and
safety training
frankly uh this is a big challenge
because identifying people who are at
risk and what their particular risks are
according to their job exposures as well
as their personal health histories
that involves really ramping up the
robustness of the occupational health
program
and that's a tall order
uh institutions are challenged to do
that but we will often see for example
with occupational health and safety
training issues
specific resources allocated well we'll
get another occupational health and
safety physician or nurse
or a health and safety professional
who's responsible for training or will
integrate the veterinarian in safety
training uh perhaps so that the specific
correction of the issue depends on the
specific gap that there is in training
but
generally it involves allocating people
time and effort and resources and that
might be new positions at the
institution or repurposing some existing
positions that's typically what we see
well if there are no further questions
from our audience i guess it's time to
wrap it up i want to
thank everyone in the audience for their
questions and for participation in
today's event
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing
through august 2015
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay
we invite you to forward that
announcement to any of your colleagues
who may have missed this event we hope
to see you again soon thank you and
goodbye